so what it what are some of the big
things you've learned from
chameleon-like Kevin Hart for instance
or a Patrice O'Neal like what are some
things big takeaways you've learned from
being around these kind of people
Patrice O'Neal man the best advice he
ever gave me a have an opinion but don't
let the opinion have you know you know
that basically means that you know you
you can you can say somebody don't be so
arrogant to not be open to what someone
else is because they could teach you
something and give you a whole nother
perspective that you never even thought
of so you know have an opinion but don't
let your opinion have you mmm
what about Kevin Hart Kevin Hart one
thing that I learned about from him and
yes I think that you know everybody
could take away because he's won the
most hardest-working comedians ever yeah
well and it's just be consistent be
consistent man and be resilient and you
know wake up early I would say just be
consistent in work work work hard
his ethic is unmatched what about a
little Duvall Lil Duval taught me how to
be jack reuler and you know this
basically not to believe everything I
hear and to you know always be
accountable he he also helped me get it
learn how to work the internet he given
age on it
he's a really he's a genius when it
comes to social media yes
yeah and the music now the music
unbelievable hopped all the way off but
we've been doing music
and he found one and he changed history
yeah
he's part of Black History Month he was
a day they talked about him on Jeopardy
come on really
yes he was a Jeopardy question would it
what does that like to be seeing these
these cats you came up with because you
guys are in the trenches together like
y'all came up up together
but what is it like now I know your time
is coming you show you show me who your
friends are and I show you what your
future mmm I have yeah yeah so is this
one of those things man stop hanging
around janky [__] man and
getting around people that are doing
things and you know really maximizing
off life and understand that you only
live once and so you better go ahead and
everyday live it to the fullest and do
what you really want to do don't waste
your time time is the only thing you
can't get back mm-hmm and one of my
favorite quotes from our first interview
was you had said I believed in myself
before anyone else did oh yeah most like
in comedy it can be such like a lonely
gradual process it's like what how did
you and you're in those hard times early
in the grind like how did you overcome
that self-doubt how did you break
through and just keep going I don't I
don't want to be that that comedian or
that just a person in life where people
just felt sorry for when I wanted to be
a winner and I wanted to win by all cost
and whatnot sorry I just made up in my
mind that I was gonna work hard and I
wasn't gonna look like no sucker no bum
and whatnot and I would get down on it
so I just made a choice to win I made a
choice to be happy by any means
necessary this is like a mindset yeah
it's a mine isn't all mine it's all mine
sighs oh my is the Auto Wars mental ooh
[Music]
can you expand on that you know like I
said you you you you have to you can
wheel yourself into a great situation
but you have to always be able to see
yourself inside those successful
situations and whatnot and anything
start envisioning on how to get there
and you you can't allow yourself to be
distracted
come in all different types of forms
friends vices situations
backup plans you have to stay on the
path
remember what you came here for and
follow through don't take the easy way
out follow through don't look left don't
look right and damn sure don't look back
only way out is through mmm and he's all
mental you even said like visualize you
like picture and success and they
collect like offenses I wrote down some
I've set of goals last year and one of
those was I'm gonna be a major a major
tour and I was gonna get a Netflix deal
and I was going to get a record deal
these are in I have friends I could call
up to you right now and tell you they'll
tell you that I said that's what I was
gonna do and I did it but I got friends
that I could I could call right now and
I told him that I was gonna come up in
New York and I was gonna meet 50 cent
and I did it I got friends right now
that I told house will be on wiling out
and no matter there's no agent mmm I did
it man so you got to see yourself inside
that situation man because that nothing
only thing the difference between you
and somebody else is that they just they
deserve to be ahead of you because they
actually try and you was thinking too
much waiting on the right time but man
sometimes waiting on the right time well
you you'll be dead for whatever right
time yeah even setting the intention I
found to be super like last year was the
first time I set like actual measurable
goals and like one of them was I want to
record a comedy album this year it just
happened that one of the fans my podcast
had a production company and was like
hey we can make this a comedy special
instead of just an album but setting the
intention to Craig now and kind of put
the whole thing in motion to now become
the trophy husband but if I didn't first
set that goal it would have never
happened
yeah but as comedians we can get lost in
just well it is what it is but I feel
like now it's time
the opportunity is bigger than ever for
us to create our own success that's
absolutely great and do you have any
tips for comics who are out there on the
hustle and are just like well how can I
start to get my own thing going you know
get your be consistent it's so many
different ways to get yourself out there
you know these things that are available
to you that you know Bruce Bruce didn't
have like social media right right like
a lot of older comedians don't have like
big s followings
they had to go out there make it happen
so but we have access to Facebook
Instagram Twitter all these the tic-tock
all these different ways to promote
yourself if you don't make it a day you
ain't opposed to make it so just make it
happen it work you gotta do the work I
remember when I was in acting classes
with Robert Townsend he said honey bun
yeah no shortcuts you got to do the work
Wow and what about 50 cent what have you
learned from working with him he said
don't ever do business with somebody
that don't respect you hmm don't ever do
business with somebody don't respect you
uh whistling today he's talking about uh
we was just talking about the other day
when he found out that I was on them too
or Martin Martin is his favorite
comedian and he was just like a man is
you did you got to get ready too
anything wrong with you changing because
people around you are going to change
and you know feel like that there was
part of your success in me actually
having to do with it because what
success breeds envy entitlement and
jealousy hmm
it's another word I'm a little bit of
work it's this 3mv
and it's not well envy and jealousy I
guess for the same thing
men be entitlement oh no no I'm not 50
cent yeah yeah of course yeah yeah
people will change up on you when you
get when you get successful people start
to switch up but like you says people
you surround yourself with
so you being in the same room as Martin
Lawrence is kind of like oh I'm in the
right place what's going on I got
long-lost cousins and [__] from 20 years
ago wanting them to because I release
you everybody thinks you're like co-star
and you guys are like gonna you're this
multi-millionaire all of a sudden
they're like let me hold something
Jacqueline right right right
not yet exactly yeah man
so maybe land in this plane here do you
have any other advice for comics or any
other lessons you've learned that you
can kind of impart onto us young
ambitious Souls
[Music]
I breath